Paul:
Are you just gonna burn down
your career and take me with you?
Coin-flip?
Ahh!
(Crash)
Get out of here.
What's on your mind today?
Like I want to change, but I’m
not particularly open to make
those changes.
I'm trying.
Every time I get rid of one
compulsion, another compulsion
comes up.
Are you yawning right now?
Spoiler alert, I feel like I'm
stuck.
Right, how does that make you
feel?
(People screaming)
(Splash)
Jimmy.
Liz, hey.
It's three in the morning.
I'm sorry.
What's in that bowl?
Pretzels.
The other bowl?
Maybe some painkillers.
Maybe?
There's painkiller in there,
yeah.
Liz:
I have to ask, is this you
forever?
Jimmy:
I don’t know.
♪Crush a bit, little bit, roll
it up, take a hit.♪
Jimmy:
Oh, hey,
Paul.
I’m worried about you, kid.
Jimmy:
I’ve been grieving her.
(Crying)
Paul:
You’ve been numbing.
Ahh!
(Crash)
Stop, you’re doing sad face.
This is just face.
I have resting dead wife face.
(Laughing)
He just kept going on and on
about how dumb I am, but he
loves me.
Your husband is emotionally
abusive.
He’s not working on it. He
doesn’t intend to. Just leave
him.
Okay.
♪I'm on the pursuit of
happiness.♪
I think I can help people
if I get my hands a little bit
dirtier.
Your mom wanted you to scatter
her ashes, right?
Jimmy:
We know what they should do.
Don’t you ever want to just
shake them?
But we don’t shake them.
Jimmy:
I take that back, run!
-Huh.
It sounds so unethical.
Are you just gonna burn down
your career and take me with
you?
Coin-flip?
Get out of here.
Wait, this is my office.
It took you longer than it
should’ve.
My patients are really thriving.
Jimmy:
This thing I’m doing is really
working.
Jimmy:
I’m right behind you.
(Yelling)
Nobody gets through this life
unscathed.
I can’t remember Mom’s laugh.
I can feel her slipping away.
Paul:
You’re faced with a choice.
Are you going to let your grief
drown you,
or are you going to face it
Paul:
come out the other side?
(Cheering)
It’s nice to see you have your
spark back.
♪♪
Sean:
You just going to leave your car
here?
I’m a white guy in Pasadena, the
cops will probably just take it
back to my house for me.
Sean:
Must be nice.
♪I'm on the pursuit of
happiness, and I know.♪
Derek, how’s it going?
Just walking the dog I didn’t
want.
My patient moved into her
sister’s start.
Sounds like the day’s off to a
great start for both of us.